muy bien nos quedamos en el problema 44
nos dice cuál es la forma factor izada
de 3 a cuadrada menos 24 ave más 48 de
cuadrada y nos dan cuatro opciones así
que lo que vamos a hacer en este
problema es simplemente factorizar lo y
ver con cuál coincide con de estas
cuatro opciones así que tenemos tres a
cuadrada menos 24 ave más 48 de cuadrada
y lo que podemos observar aquí es que
los coeficientes de estos tres términos
todos son divisibles entre 3 así que
realmente podemos factorizar primero un
3 de todo esto y entonces nos queda 3
que multiplica a cuadrada menos 3 porque
me da 28 son 3 por 8 nos queda ave más 3
porque me da 48 o bien 48 entre 3
simplemente son 16 y agregamos ese b
cuadrada muy bien entonces estas dos son
igualdades
y ahora lo único que nos queda es
factorizar esta expresión y esta
expresión simplemente la si nos damos
cuenta en realidad tiene dos variables
digamos la clave
podríamos ahorita pensar por un momento
que la a es como mi variable x que
siempre utilizo para los polinomios
cuadra ticos así que podemos pensar como
x hilos y los números bueno son los son
los que siempre satisfacen esta relación
de que tenemos que encontrar dos números
que sumados me den menos 8 b de hecho
déjenme escribirlo de esa forma vamos a
tener tres veces a cuadrada y aquí vamos
a agrupar esto así menos 8 b que
multiplica vamos a ponerlo así menos 8 b
que multiplica a más 16 b cuadrada
entonces si mía es digamos el término
que equivale digamos a la equis que
siempre he utilizado con polinomios
entonces me pregunto dos números que
sumados me den menos 8 b
y multiplicados me den 16 b cuadrada
entonces de esta primera parte no
tenemos que esto es positivo entonces
necesito 2 números negativos pero además
o bueno pueden ser dos números negativos
o dos números positivos pero la suma
debe ser negativa por lo tanto no puedo
tener dos números positivos porque la
suma de positivos
me quedaría positiva así que aquí
realmente lo que voy a necesitar son dos
números negativos y ahora bien esos
números van a estar en términos de b
tenemos que expresar lo en términos de b
pero bueno si si omitimos tantito la b
podremos ver que si hay dos números que
sumados me den menos 8 y multiplicados
16 verdad por ejemplo menos 4 y menos 4
sin embargo aquí debe aparecer una vez
entonces podemos poner menos 4 b que si
le sumamos menos 4 b nos dan menos 8 b y
menos 4 b x menos 4 b esto es menos 4 b
al cuadrado que justamente son nuestras
16 b cuadrada muy bien entonces en
realidad esto nos quedó en términos de b
no debe confundirnos confundirnos más
allá simplemente la la vemos digamos
como nuestra variable x y lo que me
queda entonces es que esto es igual a
tres veces que multiplica la
factorización de esto y ya vimos que es
a menos 4 b x a menos 4 b y que esto
coincide muy bien con nuestra opción c
muy bien vamos a hacer el siguiente
ejercicio el 45 cual es un factor de x
cuadrada menos 11 x más 24 entonces
déjenme anotarlo nuevamente x cuadrada
menos 11 x más 24 y tenemos que
factorizar lo ahora bien también lo que
podríamos hacer es bueno vamos a vamos a
factorizar lo ya después les comento un
poquito al respecto entonces y aquí
nuevamente nos preguntamos dos números
que sumados me den menos 11 y que
multiplicados me den 24 nuevamente éste
es un número positivo por lo tanto
necesito tomar dos números positivos o
dos números negativos ahora como la suma
debe ser negativa pues no pueden ser
ambos positivos así que tienen que ser
negativos los dos y podemos pensar en
los factores de 24 y rápidamente podemos
encontrar que 8 por 3 son 24 entonces
voy a tomarme menos 8 y menos 3 que al
sumar nos nos da menos 11 verdad menos 8
más
23 es menos 11 menos 8 x menos 3 es 24
así que estos dos me funcionan por lo
tanto esta expresión de aquí se
factorizar como x menos ocho que
multiplica a x menos 3 y ahora nos
fijamos cuál de estos dos factores se
encuentra aquí y bueno es el de la
opción b y a diferencia de lo que podría
ser resolver la ecuación esto no es
resolver la ecuación aquí simplemente
estamos factor izando expresando lo como
un producto de dos dedos polinomios de
primer grado sale entonces a diferencia
de resolver la ecuación si resolvemos la
ecuación nosotros estaríamos buscando
aquellos x tales que esto fuera a cero
verdad o qué equivalentemente esto fuera
a cero y por lo tanto si un producto es
cero pues entonces alguno de estos dos
tiene que ser cero si éste es cero
tenemos x menos ocho igual a cero y por
lo tanto x es igual a 8 o bien x es
igual a 3 pero bueno ya me estoy yendo
por la tangente no es lo que nos
pidieron pero sólo hay que aclarar
esa diferencia así que vámonos con otro
otro ejercicio vamos a ver
en este ejercicio cuál de las siguientes
expresiones muestra a 9 t cuadrada + 12
t 4 factor izado entonces lo que tenemos
que hacer es va a actualizar este este
polinomio de aquí y esto es bastante
interesante porque a diferencia del
primer ejemplo aquí tenemos a 9
multiplicando a t cuadrada pero 9 no
divide a ninguno de los otros dos
entonces tenemos que ingeniar
ingeniarnos un poco como poder resolver
este problema entonces va a ser un poco
un reto a nuestra inteligencia sin
embargo lo que podemos notar y de una
forma digamos de irnos aproximando es
que veamos que aquí tenemos tres t
cuadrada que esto es un número al
cuadrado verdad esto es 3 t x 3 t
entonces lo que podemos hacer es digamos
nosotros proponer una factorización
digamos que sea 3 t más algún número que
no he determinado aún que multiplica a 3
t más otro número que aún no he
determinado muy bien entonces lo que
ahora necesito ver es si x
pensándolo de esta forma yo puedo
encontrar algún valor de a y algún valor
de b
de tal suerte que al multiplicarlos nos
dé justamente esto que tenemos aquí
arriba entonces vamos a desarrollar esto
y ver que deben cumplir a y b y entonces
si desarrollamos tenemos tres t por tres
t son 9 d cuadrada de ahí que que
propusiera a tres de verdad para que me
diera esta expresión y luego tres de x
por por b
3 t por b sería más 3 b t luego a por 3
3 serían otros 3 ate y luego a por de
simplemente es a b que si esto lo lo
agrupamos estos dos porque tienen un
término común que éste esto es 9 t
cuadrada también podemos factorizar un 3
3 multiplica a b más a porte más ave muy
bien entonces fíjense muy bien realmente
lo que tenemos es que la suma de estos
dos números ahí ve multiplicado por tres
me debe dar 12 y su producto debe ser 4
en pocas palabras lo que necesitamos es
que si 3 por este número me dado se
quiere decir que esta suma debe ser 4
verdad 4 por 3 son 12 entonces además b
debe ser 4 y al mismo tiempo a por b
debe ser 4 entonces necesito pensar dos
números que sumados me den 4 y
multiplicados me den 4
así que lo primero que a mí se me ocurre
es tomarme 2 2 2 4 y 2 y 2 2 por 2
perdón son 4 entonces lo que tenemos es
que esto se factorizar como 3 t más 2 y
3 t más 2 que en pocas palabras es 3 t
más 2 x sí mismo dos veces que es
elevarlo al cuadrado y eso corresponde
muy bien con nuestra opción a digo
también podía pudimos haber multiplicado
todos es todas estas opciones lo bueno
de tener
las opciones múltiples esta la tenemos
que descartar por supuesto porque no es
factorización de nada y si desarrollamos
estas tres opciones pues tenemos que ver
cuál nos da esta esta expresión de aquí
arriba vámonos con otro ejemplo más dice
cuál es la factorización completa de 32
menos 8 se está cuadrada entonces lo que
podemos hacer es bueno si tomamos 32
menos 8 se está cuadrada y podemos
darnos cuenta que podemos factorizar
1818 entonces me queda 8 que multiplica
32 entre 8 es 4
muy bien - z cuadrada
muy bien entonces tenemos 8 que
multiplica a menos a perdón a 4 - se
está cuadrada muy bien entonces como
como podemos expresar esto en realidad
lo que me invita esto a pensar es qué
pasa si uno tiene en general
esta expresión digamos de la forma
cuadrada menos b cuadrada y si nos damos
cuenta para cualesquiera dos números a
más b por a menos b te invito a que
hagas este producto sería un muy buen
ejercicio para que repases producto de
polinomios pero si hacemos esto
simplemente me queda a cuadrada menos b
cuadrada entonces lo que tenemos que
hacer es utilizar esta expresión en esta
de acá arriba porque aquí tengo una
diferencia de números al cuadrado en
este caso nuestra a vale 2 y nuestra b
vale zeta
2 iceta muy bien porque aquí 2 al
cuadrado sería 4 iceta al cuadrado pcc
está cuadrada muy bien entonces si esto
es cierto y te invito a que lo hagas tú
como un ejercicio
simplemente me queda 8 que multiplica a
4 - eta cuadrada que es 2 + zeta
según esta fórmula por 2 menos
y esto nuevamente coincide muy bien con
nuestra expresión en b entonces espero
te hayan servido estos ejercicios de
todas formas nos vemos en el próximo
vídeo